[Music]
[Music]
in complex end games
terms that hopefully you are able to
understand
now night end games are a really really
interesting beast
to tackle uh not like a horse beast
but you know like a a beast of an end
game
uh why is that well knights are often
considered
sort of the least powerful piece aside
from pawns you can argue
if bishops are better in some cases but
especially
in end games against pawns knights tend
to not do very well
right knights just don't do a good job
at controlling pawns
they don't even do a good job at um
keeping uh keeping their own pawns
defended
uh but um yeah
so it's it's interesting to try to use
them uh in these end games with pawns on
the board
and we're gonna take a look at some of
how that works out
in tonight's lecture so to start with i
want to show you guys a little bit of a
puzzle here
oh that's not right a little bit of a
puzzle here
on your board okay so this is actually
taken
from a game between two players known as
eingorn
and beliavsky in the 1986 ussr
championship so it's of course white to
move here
uh although maybe that's not actually
uh apparent from from the position and i
want to talk a little bit about
knights and rook pawns so of course
white is trying to win this game
against black's defense with with only
one pawn
on the board this is where we are going
to start
so chat room what are some ideas that
sort of stick out to you
in in this position let's let's start
here
and say jacob molina already has a
really interesting
idea really interesting idea
so oftentimes the best way to try to
win the game uh with knights is to
sacrifice your own
in order to deflect the enemy knight or
the enemy
king away from the action and that is
exactly the case here we're starting off
this
rather basic example and i think white's
easiest way to win the position
is actually the counter-intuitive move
knight d4
check why is this the best way to win
well
it draws this knight further away from
stopping
this rook pawn now it would be a pretty
huge mistake to follow this up with the
idea
of h5 and we'll talk about that in a
second but white can
place the king uh two diagonal squares
opposite the knight
and this does a very effective job of
keeping this knight out of the game
it guards all of these paths of entry
into the position
that the knight can take and even this
path of entry is going to be hard
to achieve as well so basically with the
king on f6
white is doing a very very effective job
of keeping the knight out of play
and now basically no matter what black
tries you just cannot catch this
cannot catch this pawn right it'd be
great if the knight could go
to i don't know i six or something to
try and stop this punt but i6 is not on
the board
that's why rook pawns are so tough for
knights because it can only approach it
from one side
and the king is very effective at
stopping it uh
just for example let me play some moves
knight f3
uh h5 for example sorry let's let's say
knight e2 i think knight e2 is a little
bit of a better try
let's say h5 and now knight
f4 right again now h6
and okay maybe my idea wasn't that much
of a better try
but it's it's really hopeless here for
black you just can't stop
this pawn from queening right and then
white would go on to win the game with
the queen versus a knight
but let's talk about this move of h5 i
think this is something a lot of people
would be tempted to do so black to move
after h5 can black draw this position
can black draw this position
is there any way any way
for black to to even try and stop this h
pawn with the king
so far away over here on b5
chess king says 96 draws i think 96 and
gets in
the square so jacob molina sounds very
informed
on this uh this type of end game so far
and so yeah what we're starting with
here is sort of the basic theory
on a lot of these night end games so
obviously white should not have allowed
this white should control the knight
completely
but after h5 it turns out black actually
does have enough to draw
thanks to this move knight e6 and jacob
molina called it getting in the square
and that's not necessarily what it is
but there is a very specific
drawing technique that the knight has
against the rook pawn that that doesn't
need the king
at all and it's a really useful one to
know
and it sort of comes to light after the
move of
h6 exactly what is going on here
so basically there are four squares on
the board
that work for this knight to stop this
pawn from advancing
that is the square of h7 obviously the
knight in front of the pawn isn't going
to let it advance
and then from there depending on where
the white king is it'll step to f8
or g5 and then from there it's going to
step
to e6 and it turns out
that if the knight has access to these
squares any of these squares
white is not able to force the the push
of the pawn through and let's talk about
why i'll even give white
a full extra tempo here move my king
away from the action
and we'll see what white is able to do
so if i pushed h7 that's why this knight
is on e6 i can step to f8
fork the king in the pawn and
immediately end the game
by taking the pawn off the board now if
the king
is sort of wise to my tricks in plays
king f6
king f6 attacks by not an e6 stops me
from playing knight g5
that leaves me with knight f8 now you
can't play pawn to h7 for
obvious reasons if you attack me here i
come back
and this move is check if you step in
front of your pawn you're obviously not
threatening to make progress
if you step to h8 or g8 i'll come to
knight g5
step to f7 it'll come to knight g5 if
you step to f6
we're repeating and if you step to g6 i
again
don't even have to move my knight but i
could with knight f8 check it'd be fine
so if that was king g7 we'd come back to
e6
if king f7 instead now we just go to h7
king g7 king g6 and you start to see
why this position is a draw white
just continues black just continues
moving in a circle
and no harm can be done to uh
to to this knight in order to make this
pawn advance so really useful idea to
know here
if you have access to these four squares
then you cannot lose the game
and why is it useful to know this well
then black is able to draw even if the
pawn is like further
back or something you don't need to go
for
for any square stopping the pawn way far
down the board
you're able to draw if you get to these
four squares regardless of where this
pawn is unless of course it's like
already
you know immediately queening so two
really important ideas here
number one oftentimes the way to try to
win these night end games is to
sacrifice your own knight
forking or via some other tactic
forcing one of the other pieces away in
this case the knight
and then finding the way to keep the
knight out of the game
in order to push the pawn to victory
that's important idea number one
and white wins the game with this idea
here and i think this is what was played
in the game
important idea number two is this idea
of these four squares against the rope
pawn this is going to allow black
to draw the game in this case so
questions on this
questions on this if the knight touches
eight seven
h7 it's a draw in fact if the knight
touches any of these squares
it's a draw any of these squares doesn't
even have to touch h7
it can sort of indirectly do it from e6
okay let us move on then to example
number two
so this is also from a game in this case
it's from hernandez sula in 1984
and i wanted to ask you guys uh
obviously or
maybe not obviously but trust me white
is the one
pushing for the win here why is white
pushing for the win
because white has more space that's
pretty apparent right white's pawns are
closer to queening
and because of that white is going to
have more tactical ideas available
to try to win the game now perhaps you
could argue white snipe might be getting
trapped
but it always at least has sort of an
escape route
pre-made so how do you guys in the chat
room
want to approach this position for the
moment it looks really really good for
white but black seems to have
the weaknesses defended there's no
immediate path
for the king to get in and there's no
real way to
attack upon like h7 or attack upon like
b7
uh attacking d6 when it's already
defended also seems kind of pointless
so does anybody see a winning plan or
you know a winning attempt winning idea
is they're similar in g pawns and f
pawns so rook pawns are the hardest for
knights to deal with
uh with g pawns or f pawns i think the
idea
it can be similar but often times it's
even easier because the knight steps to
the other side of the pawn
that isn't available in the case of rip
pawns
looks like five o'clock traffic yeah
it's it's a pretty jammed up board here
sack on f6 and hope so you guys are
arriving at some ideas here knight takes
c5 has also been suggested
you guys are all arriving at ideas of
immediately sacrificing material so
it's worth checking i just want to say
it's worth checking for ideas
that don't involve you know the
sacrifice of major material
for for your side i'm not saying that
those aren't ever right
but it's it's worth checking for ideas
that that don't
you know lose copious amounts of of
material
so chess king is saying a lot of people
now are saying some weird idea of knight
b8 to c6
it's interesting
everybody wants to play e5 and this is
sort of confusing to me
what is what is the point of e5 tell me
your point
knight b6 is also suggested finally
somebody wants to keep the knight on the
board
everybody's like yeah kill the thing i
don't want it i don't need it
no knight required and yes this idea of
knight f8
is also appearing in the chat now as as
well knight b6 for sure
so a couple proponents of leaving
the pieces on the board but
uh yeah i have yet to really hear a
winning
idea right there are ideas but
by ideas i mean moves but i i don't see
the
point of these moves just yet
so yeah jacob would just play knight b6
but it doesn't feel like a puzzle
solution so
yeah this is the first thing you should
be checking okay like i know i'm giving
a lecture and i'm showing you a position
so you're inclined to look for the the
pretty moves
but you should think about knight f6 or
knight b6 not
i guess you should think about knight f6
but not too hard you should think about
knight b6 first
before anything else why is that well
because you just want to see if
you know you can bring this knight you
can weasel your way
almost anywhere on the board maybe this
is a winning plan
right you know it takes like 12 moves
but maybe this
is a winning plan uh and it's worth
thinking about these things right it's
worth thinking about
and refuting this idea
uh now does this idea actually win i
don't know i honestly just came up with
this off the cuff
i would tend to think that white would
be better here but maybe this isn't
entirely necessary like let's say this
happens for example
maybe black is even able to to come over
to d7
and your idea is going to be tough to
execute
uh maybe the point here is that this
knight actually gets trapped that's
that's kind of funny
that's kind of funny but okay back to
the initial position so knight b6 is
fine
knight b6 doesn't spoil anything and i
think knight b6 is
a perfectly acceptable way to uh to play
the game
um that being said e5 is the type of
move that
doesn't do anything i don't why do you
play e5 like black just takes it i don't
understand this
i don't understand knight takes c5
this is an interesting idea but
unfortunately this one also loses
as well right black just takes it and
yeah now you've made it past pawn and so
i think it's a bit more interesting than
e5
but at the cost of a knight it's it's
not going to get you anywhere
black is ready to blockade and black is
actually winning the game now
so that leaves us with a couple ideas
knight takes f6
is like e5 except even worse because you
just lose a full piece again for nothing
but the key to knight end games is to
understand
that knights are the worst right this is
the key knights are the worst so you
guys were right to be thinking of all
these ideas where you just give up a
night
but that being said nights are the worst
so kings become all the more powerful
so often times the winning idea doesn't
even involve the knights at all
the winning idea involves the king you
want to find a way for the white king
to invade in the position and that's how
you arrive at the winning move
which as the chat has mentioned is
knight f8 uh
why is this crazy looking move you know
winning
because it's with the idea of bringing
the king
in it's forcing the black king away as
we've said a distraction
a deflection in order to uh you know
give us some gain in the first puzzle
the gain was pushing the h pawn and
making the queen in this puzzle
the game is invading with their king and
it turns out that this is in fact
going to be a winning idea so
night end games first thing to remember
knights are the worst
don't be too afraid to uh to look for
ideas of sacrificing them oftentimes
it's the only way to win
um second rule because the knights are
bad the kings become
very very important as we see here for
example
king takes f8 king e6 and all of a
sudden
this knight is is actually sort of
entombed right you can check
and come to a8 but you can't go any
further right
this this knight is is too too stuck
uh in the game i believe black actually
tried knight
to g7 but this is not quite good enough
white is able now to just take the
take the free knight think even king
takes d6 as winning
but perhaps taking the knight is simpler
king d6
h5 king e7 now is
important h4 and both sides make a big
queen
but unfortunately for black
the black's queen is just just not good
enough here
check for example and i think this is
how the game actually ended there was
like a check
and i think uh king f7 here and that is
gonna be the match gonna be the match oh
sorry maybe not king of seven
hold on i didn't actually import the
actual game i just had the position from
the game so i'm not 100 certain how the
game ended
i think yeah i think king f7 and then
the point is like something like this
and and we win and we win
so knight f8 key idea to remember
key key key idea to remember nights are
the worst
nights are really bad nights nights are
so bad
so what do you do you throw them away in
an effort to invade with your king
so questions on this puzzle and i went
through that last part pretty quickly
the point is you are able to invade with
the king
what's the alternatives taking if you
don't h7 falls and white has a king
um yeah no no i agree black sort of has
to take
you can try playing king to g8 but but
now i think
uh i i think it's all bad for black you
can even take h7 and then just continue
with the same
or you can go 96 98 and i think now this
king is
slightly too far away maybe not actually
maybe not yeah
i think you just take on h7 here
alternatively even knight g6 or
something but
i think you just take a h7 and this is
more of the same in this case we
don't take the knight on g7 but now
black doesn't even have a pawn
and we will be queening uh in short
order
in short order or maybe i have to do
this i don't know there's
complications so king jade is worth
thinking about though king j is worth
thinking about but
it does look like knight h7 is is still
the winning move
even knight g6 is perhaps winning with
the point being that you can do this
but okay knight h7 but yeah king takes
f8 other questions
other questions
why do you need to take the knight okay
so there's only two moves uh the point
of knight f8 is that it attacks the pawn
on h7
so you either have to take this knight
or play king g8 and the response to king
g8 is to take on h7
if you do nothing i'm going to take this
pawn and then
take this pawn and then queen my pawn
and that'll be very very sad
move the knight to c2 then push pawns i
died
that those words don't make any sense to
me
even just king e6 yeah maybe king e6 is
good enough uh i thought for some reason
it wasn't
from my vague memory yeah maybe here
maybe here black is holding on i go king
f8 king of sudden for the rest of the
game or something
could be could be
maybe even have five ideas and i escape
okay would have calculated out of fate
for 10 minutes and then played knight b6
yeah it's easier to do in a puzzle
but yeah knight b6 doesn't spoil things
by the way you can come back and play
nada fate later if you really want
but uh the point is knight f8 is a good
idea to keep in mind
the point isn't necessarily that you
find knight f8 100 times out of 100 in
your own games if you get a position
like this
the point is that you at least consider
ideas like knight f8 it's important to
understand
that these night sacrifices are way more
common than any other
type of end game right you very very
rarely see in a bishop end game and
especially your rook end game
you sacrificing the rook just for like
the king to invade
right that that very rarely works this
is something that's sort of unique to
night end games
where sacrificing the knight is just
sort of always your idea in many many
positions
uh with that let us move on to a
quote-unquote
classic endgame that we're going to take
a look at from the perspective of
one nimzovich against lasker
this is all garbage nobody cares about
this what is this middle game
approaching an endgame wait too many
rooks on the board way too many rooks on
the board
okay can we get rid of these rooks uh
okay
rooks are gone rooks are gone what do
you guys think
about this night end game what do you
guys think don't look at who won
don't i know i know it's right here but
don't look at it what do you think
use your own brain here
why not the bishop well bishops are just
a lot better at playing against the
pawns
than than knights are so it's a lot
harder to get away with sacrificing a
bishop in a bishop versus bishop end
game
because the opposing bishop is often
able to stop any idea that you had
what do you mean by knights are too bad
so sort of what is
shown in one form by uh the first
example i showed
knights are just not great at stopping
pawns and pawns often work very well
against knights so in night versus night
end games with pawns on the board
it's very common to be to be sacrificing
the knight for
some sort of game even if it's only a
couple tempi
it can make all the difference whereas
bishops are a lot better at stopping
pawns because they can sort of plant
themselves anywhere on the board and
attack the squares in front of pawns
they can attack the pawns directly so
that's that's why
so yeah here's the key right
uh a couple people are mentioning
that the key difference here is these
two pawns
and yeah for the moment it looks like
black's knight is better than white's
knight
but i would argue that this knight is is
going to lose the tempo eventually
white's going to hit the knight with the
king and then the knight has to move
and then we're actually losing time or
something
so the key difference here is not really
knight placement knights are bad doesn't
matter where they are
the key difference is that the outside
past pawn belongs to nimesovic
not only that it's a rook pawn and
knights are
as we learned in the first example very
very bad at stopping rook pawns they
have this sort of one idea
of going around on the four squares in
front of a pawn
but aside from this it's very very
difficult for knights to stop
pawns to stop rook pawns
and even puns in general but especially
rook punts so
this pawn being an outside passer and
being a rook pawn makes it difficult for
lasker to defend here now i want to
introduce sort of
another rule for your brains here
and this is a rule that is sort of uh
you know contested so take this with a
grain of salt
botfinic i believe came up with the rule
and the rule is
night end games are just king and games
okay
what does this rule mean well it goes
back to the idea
that knights are pretty bad at anything
involving pawns
because the knights are so bad often
times the same rules that are used in
king and pawn end games can be applied
in knight and pawn and games and that
holds true here
so with knights off the board this would
be an easy easy win
for uh for uh for black let's let's take
the knights off the board why not why
not take the knights off the board
after all
okay blank wins easily right white has
to come all the way over here to stop
this pawn
and black sorry we'll try a little bit
harder
and black just comes and takes the
king's side pawns
so there you go
knight end games are king end games so
black should win easily
now where this rule sort of breaks down
uh
is when you actually realize that things
are a lot more complex
when knights are on the board so what
this rule can tell you
is that black should be better here
because of these rules we have from king
and pawn end games
uh is black actually winning well it
remains to be
to be seen it's going to be a lot more
difficult than in the simple king vs
king end game
because lasker is in fact able to
blockade this pawn with the knight and
still play in the center of the board
with
the king so let's take a look at what
happens uh
it starts much the way you would expect
pretty simply both sides
bring their kings into the game so king
f7 by nimzovich king c1 king f6
king d2 king e5 king e3 uh
great start so far now black continues
to play naturally with the move h5
and we see a3 and a5
by black so this move i do want to talk
about just a little bit
but then we'll get into the the really
important stuff in
in just a moment here so a3 and a5
so as the attacking side it can be good
to take some space
with your pawns in order to create
threats sort of on this side of the
board
as well you know it's just a lot faster
to promote with
your pawns starting in a5 than with your
pawn starting on a seven so taking space
is often a very common idea to try and
play for the win
but at the same time you don't want to
over extend your pawns
when white might be able to find counter
play against them so a5
is a nice move by nimzovich
white now plays this uh knight out to h3
and we'll see here that nimzovich goes
on a quick journey and then we're gonna
pause
and talk so nimzovich decides to bring
this knight over to the king's side
to try and interfere with this night's
blockade of the pawn
we see king f3 now knight h4 check king
e3
knight g6 and now knight g5 and
this is where i want to pause and talk
so nimzovich has you know brought this
knight on a little bit of a journey
from the d4 square over to the g6 square
and it's to help support the pawn with
the knight so the idea to take away from
that little journey is just that
nimsovich
wants to support the h pawn with the
knight
while the kings are sort of battling in
the center
but now it comes time to
find a way to make substantial progress
with uh with black here so we need
a plan to make progress so what ideas
are sticking out to you chat try not to
just give me one or two moves
try to give me a plan to make
progress
so yeah i don't want to offend any fans
of knights as pieces i
i love i love them as pieces middle
games they can be really great
if you get them on a nice outpost
they're super strong pieces
but sort of indisputably in end games
i think they are the worst piece against
pawns
i think they are the worst piece against
the pawns
okay so some moves are are showing up
but uh
who would i consider the best between
kappa blank and alkyne i'm not the
biggest chess historian to be honest
um uh you know i i refer you to the list
that chess24 put out of the top 100
chess players
check the list i trust them
okay let me try to read some of these
plans that people are saying now
how much does the horse be worth in this
position would you give the a in the b
pawns for the horse
so that's uh unfortunately not
not really a a question you can ask
right
if black could trade this knight for
those two pawns i think he would but
that's sort of never
really happening here never really
happening and that would just depend on
the specifics on if the pawns are going
to clean or not it comes very concrete
so manny says control the squares the
white knight also controls with the move
knight f4
uh pivot tracks his knight affords take
control of h3 so we can push
h5 h4 dimitri says protect the pawn
while pushing it
chess king says distract white and try
to play
on the queen side that is an interesting
idea
check the king with the knight try to
force it to the side
fix the pawns with a4 and then maneuver
the knight to
attack great wolf says is the horse a
donkey
uh unclear so yeah knight of four i
think loses tactically
right i think loses tactically to knight
f3 check
seems tough right seems tough um so
interesting
that nobody suggested the move h4
so i think h4 is is actually going to be
a little bit wrong in this position
uh and what's the reason for that well
this pawn is actually a little bit over
extended now white is able to both
sort of uh include threats of attacking
this pawn
on h4 or sadly stopping it from
from moving and also playing on the
queen's side uh
or even potentially sort of coming after
this pawn
with with the king so i think h4 is just
a little bit
uh a little bit premature in fact there
are even ideas of knight f7 check for
example
uh when after something like king to f6
or
king to e6 something like knight d6
could happen
and next thing you know you are losing
pawns on the queen side of the board
and you're not stopping this king from
stopping your pawn
and i think this would would be leading
quite quickly to a draw
so distracting the knight to the queen
side really isn't going to be
enough here white uh white's probably
best defensive plan
is to stop the pawn with the king and go
after black's pawns on the on the queen
side with
the knight so that is why something like
h4 would be premature so why do i start
with this line well i start with this
line to show you
how white should be trying to defend
white should be trying to go after these
pawns on the queen side with the knight
and trying to stop the pawn with the
king this way
white can sort of liquidate things on
the queen side already have the king
back on the king's side stopping the
pawn
come back with the knight draw agreed
easy peasy
let's take a look at how this might
shake out though something like king g5
king f3 should be played stopping the
king
b5 knight a5 95 check
king g4 and it looks like we're we're
making progress but unfortunately
things are coming much too slowly we
would much rather have the knight
trying to stop the pawn and the king on
the queen's side then vice versa
as seen here kings are a lot better than
knights at stopping pawns
for example knight b3 h3 check king h1
knight f3 and we're like stalemated but
still mate is not checkmate
and now any number of moves are are
going to be good enough here
for white uh even a4
knight c5 and knight takes a4
the fact of the matter is with the white
king in the corner
black is is actually unable to to drive
it away
and win the game in any sort of
reasonable time let's say king g3 for
example
knight takes a 4 something like h2
i think knight c3 is the easiest and
again it's just way too slow now
for uh for black to get in any sort of
knight f2 ideas
it's it's just way too slow so
white's defensive idea important to know
is
whoops spoiling things a little bit is
to
come to the queen side with the knight
and attack these pawns harass these
pawns go after these pawns
to to try and win the game so
with that in mind our winning plan is
going to be
to prevent black's drawing plan in this
case and that's how you can come up with
the move
king to f6 the point is you're stopping
this knight
from having access to the queen side of
the board and if white dares play the
move knight to f3
we can respond now with knight e5
and now if something like knight d4
uh the story is a little bit different
now uh
with the knight on e5 uh why is the
story a little bit different
well because now our knight is
supporting our pawn
and let's say white tries similar things
like coming after these pawns here uh
well now for one we can just defend and
sorry again a lot of it is down to
specifics i'm trying to talk in
generalities as well so it can be tough
but the point is our knight centrally
placed is slowing down this plan of
attacking on the queen side
a lot more than in the previous line
right all of the key squares are being
defended by this knight
so what white tries instead is this
check
and we actually get one repetition in
the game and then after check
the king comes to e7 and this is
uh sort of part two of the key idea we
stop the knight
from accessing the queen's side of the
board and then we play this slightly
strange looking move
of king to e7 with the point that we are
gonna go after these pawns on the queen
side with our knight
draw the king to the queen side and
leave white with the knight
trying to stop the rook pawn so that was
a lot of words but i can
basically boil it down to black's
winning plan here
is to bring white's king to the queen
side leaving the knight
on the king's side white's drawing plan
is to bring the knight to the queen's
side
leaving the king on the king's side
because
knights are bad at stopping rook pawns
kings are good at stopping pawns
and so it's all about trying to get this
balance
between the pieces so that's why we get
these crazy looking moves like king f6
and king e7 nimzovich understands that
he needs to stop the knight
from coming to the queen side and
attacking the pawns so questions on this
plane this is really really key here
really really key
questions here before we we see the rest
apparently the logo is blinking maybe
i'll turn off the tv i'm sorry
no questions about this sorry i i i
don't think i did the best
job of explaining that with this
specific example
but but here the importance is
knight stuck on king's side king goes to
queen side
not other way around that's what it is
okay
let's continue that knight g5 and knight
e5
by black and now once again we see
that black's idea is to stop the white
knight from coming back
to the queen side of the board this is
how nimzovich is trying to win the end
game
now king d4 is played but at this point
it's too late for the white knight to
come back in
so we're happy to play the move king d6
once again
keeping in mind that we are keeping this
knight under control
now after knight h3 uh it is fine to
start with the move of h4 but black
actually starts with the move of a4 here
again keeping in mind threats on both
sides of
the board knight of four was played in
the game now we do continue through with
h4
now knight h3 and uh
there's actually a really incredible two
move sequence here played
by nimzovich so
i i won't ask you to try to find it
because i think it's a little bit
obscene to ask people to try to find it
so i'll just tell you
what's going on here basically black
wants to
put white into zouzvan white black wants
to
create threats on the queen side drawing
the king further away
and then come after the knight on the
king's side to promote the pawn
right this is black's plan this is what
i've been talking about
but there's a difference between having
the knight on h3
and having the knight on f4 and the
difference is the knight is
better placed on one of these squares
controlling more squares
so for that reason uh nimsovich chooses
to play b6
followed by b5 right and it's
just to get the knight back to h3 as
opposed to on the the f4 square
that's that's the point here uh and then
we see nimzovich following up with
knight c6 check
king uh the king comes back to e3
in the game and we'll talk about that in
a second as well and now king c5 black
again making threats on the queen side
of the board king d3
and now black's idea comes to fruition
with the move b4
uh a takes b4 king takes b4 and now
finally
this king is relegated to the queen side
for fear of black making a second past
pawn
uh and at this point uh the the game is
pretty much over
but uh we see nimzovich proving that the
knight is worse on h3
via his next two moves with knight d4
check and 96
and this is why nimzovich wasted that
tempo with b6 b5
he wanted to put this knight in this
dominating position making sure this
knight on h3
couldn't move this wouldn't be possible
of course with the knight on
f4 which would not be possible uh okay
and the rest of the game is pretty
simple you see king a2 and then black is
just in time
to come to the king's side now that the
white king has been distracted
and black is just in time to stop
white's night pawn
and white is not in time to save this
knight so for example here
knight f4 check well in this position by
the way lasker resigns but for example
knight of four check
takes b6
uh sorry knight e6 not knight d not uh
95
here and there is a check to
stop the pawn and win the game uh
okay so what happened here what happened
here
right we really started thinking from
this key position with the king on e5
and the point i tried to get across is
that we need this knight to not be
attacking these pawns on the queen side
we need this knight relegated to the
king's side and only then
are we going to try to draw the king
away in order to win that's our winning
plan
draw the king to the queen side keep the
night on the king's side and then go
after the knight
in order to win so step one was boxing
this knight in
with this idea of king e7 followed by 95
okay step two was
taking all the space on the queen side
of the board with a4
and b5 then uh creating weakness with b4
that weakness being on b2 then once the
king is drawn away
we re-route the knight in order to
harass this knight
and finally we come over with our king
and win the game right that was the
process that nimzovich
used to win so was
lasker helpless was there nothing that
could have been done
in this game in order to save it i
wonder
so what do you think chatroom what do
you think questions on this winning plan
and then ideas for improvements for
white
ideas for improvements
ideas for improvements
easy next oh ho so you might think
so you might think
so yeah peter peterson says uh play on
both sides
use the short range knight to your
advantage that was your idea
and yeah in a sense this is correct but
it's important to understand
that the the roles the pieces are
playing makes a huge
huge difference you want yes to play
on both sides first and foremost taking
advantage of the fact that both of
both the king and the knight are short
range pieces but specifically
you want the knight to be the one trying
to stop the pawn
and the king to be the one trying to
defend on the other side of the board
the reason for this is because the
knight is very bad at stopping the pawn
and the king is not very bad at stopping
the pawn
why not king to c2 instead of a2 as
demonstrated so i can look at that
really quickly and then we'll talk about
some
drawing ideas so at this is at the very
end i think this question
um and it's white king a2 and why not
king c2 and the answer is
simply king c4 and you are even further
away
from taking this a pawn so the you know
the
the win is sort of even more apparent
here if you try to
for example meet this will sorry you
can't do this because then
knight f4 is going to be good enough but
uh
you can't for example just like try to
okay yeah i don't know how to phrase it
i'm trying to like find some example
line for white but
none of them makes sense because even
here there's like king b3 but let's say
you go king d2 and i go king d4
you can't just try to meet me on the the
king side of the board here
because i'm going to take your e pawn
and eventually you're gonna have to come
back
to to save this pawn there's sort of no
getting around it
like this this stuff is just not good
enough not good enough
anything is winning here king f3 for
example
knight c5 is probably the uh the best
and this one is it's just going to be
winning just going to be winning
okay but drawing ideas for uh
for white let's talk about it from
what position let's talk about it from
this position
okay you're playing with the white
pieces here your opponent just played h4
and nimsovich is about to unleash upon
you the power of wasting a tempo
so white to move here how can we try
to draw let's think about it from this
position in particular
let's think about it in this position
because i don't want to ask you just
like
in general right how do you draw because
that's a tougher question answer let's
talk about it first specifically
and then see if we can glean any ideas
from it
wait to move and try to draw the
position
okay peter peterson says get the king to
the
h file pound says
knight d5 king c3 to b4
king e3 with black as king c5 king c3
king e3 king e3 92
let's get really away says man well
there's a better try than what happened
in the game
we'll leave it leave it at that and
so yeah uh the the core idea here is is
not actually to try to get the king
to the king's side uh because of the way
that nimzovich has played this
this idea is sort of way too slow uh you
you just
you don't get there right you just don't
get there
you just don't get there in time
right you've traded one pawn for two and
against connected past pawns the knight
is definitely not going to be able to
stop them
but the idea for white is the idea that
we see
in many end games and that is to try
to liquidate the material so i think uh
white's best try here is maybe we can
follow the game even for a couple more
turns
b6 for example b5
and now here definitely and
maybe even in the position i first
showed the idea is going to go
along the lines of king to c3 now why is
this the idea
rather than uh knight h3 in king e3 as
played in the game
well white's point is very simple white
wants to
trade off these two pawns and then
rush back to the king's side and be just
willing to give up a knight for
for the pawn that's all that white wants
to do white wants to get these pawns off
the board
and then try to draw the game and i
think it's actually enough here
for lasker to uh to drop if i'm
remembered
so let's say for example that black
plays
as in the game with the move knight c6
now white is simply going to be playing
the move b3
and if you try for example king to c5
i'm simply going to take on
a4 take on a4
and the question now is how are you
actually intending to make progress here
maybe that move isn't actually the
greatest by the way let's say
no let's go ahead and say this let's say
this right king d6 and
i come back to f4 how are you intending
to to make any progress here
right if you run your king to the
queen's to the king side of the board
um sorry you can't even step here
because of this
but if you try to run your king over to
the king's side
sorry you can't step there because of
this either uh tough
but the point i'm trying to get across
if you if you try to run the king over
here
and the point is you're not even going
to be in time anymore not even going to
be in time
for example knight h3 king e5
and i think king b5 is in fact going to
be enough here
and now uh unlike the game because white
has
tried proactively to liquidate things on
the queen's side
rather than waiting for black to do it
on his terms
white is going to be able uh to draw
this game uh in time now so the idea for
white to try to draw is this king c3
move
and simplify things on the queen side
get counter play there
before black is fully set up to to come
after the pawn on
the king's side uh okay by the way
though
black sort of has one more trick here
and that is
b4 check ah bet you didn't see b4
check coming did you nobody ever sees b4
check coming so
chat room white to move and draw here
white to move and draw
chad is saying you know de veretsky is
for ultra geniuses those puzzles hurt
what if i told you these puzzles appear
in devaretsky's endgame manual you're
doing it right now
you're solving devaretsky's endgame
manual
yeah okay literally everybody in the
chat uh okay besides maybe one
has the right idea if you take this then
black has very serious winning chances
again
with the move a3 when your pieces are
sort of split
right it's hard to control both of these
pawns and it's hard even to just get
your king back in front
right you go here knight c knight takes
b4
king e5 okay maybe not king e5 maybe
king e5
i don't know the point is black has
winning chances but king b2
is a lot a lot simpler when now all the
pawns are gonna die
let's say you take this one okay let's
say you take this one
take this one and now white is
in time once again to uh to draw the
game for example
king c5 i guess i i don't know
it's it's hard again to suggest moves
for uh
for black here you can't step to either
of these squares trying to get around
because knight g6 check just ends the
game
and it's hard to suggest any other sort
of winning plan
okay but i'll try let's say 96 here for
example
now knight h3 i think is good enough
king e5 even king d3 and the game is
is just to draw the king is back in time
and the game's over
so white's drawing plan simplify things
on
the queen side of the board and then
bring the king back over
to to try to draw so this is what lasker
missed and nimzovich ended up winning
this game
sort of in style so once again
any questions before we move on one more
to one more thing
and actually maybe i will just review so
yeah the point is
hopefully these puzzles slash games game
positions
are showing you the principles in action
but i will review the principles before
we
we finish up here
what if king e5 so sorry i was pointing
that out but not actually putting on the
board
um you can't ever step to either of
these squares because knight g6 is
is a problem it's a problem white's just
going to take the pawn and the game's
going to be over
okay so once again the principles we saw
in this game here starting from this
position
white's big drawing idea in this
position was to come
with knight f7 and
bring the k the knight to the queen side
in order to target black's pawns
something like this right white wants to
target black's pawns on the king's side
while stopping black's pawn on sorry
target black's pawns on the queen side
while stopping black's h pawn from being
a threat
so what does nimsovich do in response to
this well he
forces the knight to be the piece trying
to guard the pawn that's the principle
to take away
knights are bad at stopping rock pawns
if you're trying to win make sure that
it's the knight trying to stop the pawn
and not the enemy king so that's why we
started with these moves
of king f6 and kidney 7 after that one
repetition
from there white brings the knight back
in and we see black expertly
centralize the knight once again playing
against
this knight's access to the queen side
of the board
we saw king before king d6 now knight h3
for white
then we saw black um pushing on the
queen side of the board to try to make a
threat on the opposite side of the board
so principle number one make the knight
the piece that stops the pawn
and the king the piece that uh you know
isn't stopping the pawn
easier than the done in many cases
number two you want to play on both
sides of the board
so we're trying to draw the white king
away and we do so
by pushing these pawns forward giving
white a weakness
white then has to defend that weakness
and then once we've improved to the
maximum
we see nimsovich go after the knight on
the king's side
and end up winning the game just in time
not with knight d5 but with 96.
uh okay and then from the defensive side
the defending plan
that uh
the defending plan where where is it
when was i looking
okay yeah the defending plan that's
white perhaps
missed flipping again was to liquidate
things on the queen's side to remove
black's threat on this side of the board
before black was able to to draw white's
pieces too far away
and get in a position to support the
h-pawn forward
so those are the principles sort of in
action here in this complex
end game so questions on this
once again before we call it a night
here and head over
to twitch with perfect play was the
initial position winning
that's a question i'm not totally
confident in answering
probably not maybe probably not
it looks like this drawing plan by
lasker well sorry this drawing plan that
lasker didn't find
is probably good enough for a draw at
least in this position
could things have happened differently
earlier maybe
how do we remember this in our own games
well you can remember
simpler things right you can remember
hey knights are bad at stopping rook
pawns
that's something i think everybody in
the chat can remember you don't need to
remember all the details about it
but you can remember knights are bad at
stopping rook pawns and then you can
sort of
come to these conclusions uh
in your own thinking right you can say
oh well the knight's bad at stopping the
pawn but it looks like the king
is sort of really effective at stopping
the pawn it stops the pawn and threatens
to take the pawn as well
so maybe you know i i don't want that
king block hating
and then you say okay well these pieces
they're they're very short range
i i can't really seem to break through
on the king's side of my own
so i need to draw people over to the to
the queen side you need to make threats
over there and then
can sort of start to come up with these
plants so the thing to do
is not remember every single specific
principle that i talked about tonight
the thing to do is train this plan
making this winning plan making skill
right you know identifying these sorts
of principles for yourself
and formulating some kind of plan using
those ideas that is the skill i'm hoping
to to train you guys on
when we do these lectures and hopefully
it's something that you guys are are
picking up on
as well uh okay i think i am going to
leave it with that
thank you all so much for joining me if
you do want more chess i'm gonna
continue next with analyze your games
live on our twitch channel so if you're
tired of me analyzing
these old games and these uh these end
games
send in something fun something of your
own and i'll take a look tell you what i
think tell you where i think you can
improve
and it'll it'll be a blast so join us on
twitch
for that uh with that in mind as always
thank you guys so much for watching
you